all right and so it's percussive too so
yeah you could join along if you if you
so choose to
feel the rhythm coming through you while
you listen to it
let's see
so something like that i hear music in
the echo
of this water falling down and the day
that you are hearing
i'll be gone from this year town you
will find me in the city
you won't find me in the streets just
look up to see me flying
you're soaring anywhere i please
wherever i please wherever
cause this world can get me down you
should try it too
you'll feel it from your feet up to your
crown
people tell us that we're crazy people
tell us that we're mad
but mentally they're lazy grasping
anything they can think they can think
they can
and you you gotta listen for echo echo
echo
and hear that sound you gotta be
here now be now i'm just here to say
it's gonna be all right
if you feel me now
live your dreams and fight
if you're feeling this you know exactly
what to do
it's not up to me or up to him
it's up to you it's up to you
it's up to you it's up to you and you
oh you gotta listen for echo echo echo
and i hear that sound you gotta be
here now be now be
always gotta give a kiss
hmm
yeah this is definitely one of my faves
i really love it